this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app I don't
know if you've seen this but the cash
app has done something amazing they've
introduced the cash card it's a new
black debit card that you can design
yourself via the app which is cool fee
artistic the cash card allows you to use
the cash that you keep in the app
anywhere you want now you have the cash
app which is the best way to pay people
back plus the all new cash card it's
really awesome I'll talk about this more
later on in the show download the free
cash app for iOS or Android now what's
up my babies how you guys doing it's the
34th episode what the [ __ ] how did we do
it we did it we keep doing it you know
I'm sitting here I got my two dogs over
here on the other side of me on my other
orange chair and they're being very cute
Sam and butters and they're sleeping and
I'm chilling this is the 34th episode I
am I was where was I this weekend I tell
you man I do the road so much and that I
don't even know I what did I do do the
road a lot yeah I don't know what the
difference between a road comic is and
me I don't I'm not a road comic maybe
world comic is just a comic that goes on
the road every single weekend but I do a
lot this September actually has been
rough because when I went to go shoot
life in a year which was the movie I did
in Toronto in May for five weeks I had
to reschedule a bunch of stuff and they
were all it was all were scheduled to
September because when I have to cancel
because I have a movie or something
really important I have to
I always like try to let the cloud like
I feel bad for the for theatres or clubs
or whatever I'm doing so I say whenever
they have a free weekend I'll do it and
they all picked September yeah
so I am where was I last weekend I
literally can remember oh no of course I
can New Brunswick New Jersey my home
state of New Jersey I played this club
the stress factory which is awesome it's
a great club
I'm [ __ ] happy that I'm at the point
where I can play the places I like and I
don't have to play [ __ ] places
really so I play in New Brunswick and I
liked I don't know dude when I I'm from
New Jersey and I don't go back to New
Jersey too much but whenever I do like
I'm not from New Brunswick I'm from I'm
from Montclair which is like 30 40
minutes from New Brunswick and I moved
when I was 12 to Los Angeles but when
I'm there like it was just feels like
home which is weird because I consider
myself a West Coast guy you know I mean
I move when I was 12 I still kind of
have a little bit of an accent
especially when I'm yelling and [ __ ] or
you know making sweet love but yeah like
we're gonna make sweet love I have a
[ __ ] serious Jersey accent like yo
you like that and not for nothing but
you like that you like me up inside you
like that you feel mean your guts babe
ah [ __ ] that feels good huh yo oh [ __ ]
yo that's how I go that's how I finish
oh yo
oh [ __ ] yo yeah you like that yo is that
good for you baby
I [ __ ] hey yo did you go to hold mine yo
you got a whole nine when I made [ __ ]
love to you or what ah [ __ ] yo you a you
want some salami that's what I do like
that I don't mean that my dick I'm in
little does she want salami out of the
refrigerator you know you want some
salami and a [ __ ] spray I'm gonna go
down to the [ __ ] in a corner store and
grab some [ __ ] you want some baby you're
the [ __ ] best I tell him to make love
so so when I when I have when I had one
so so I was staying in New Brunswick and
then we went to like we one thing about
New Jersey I love the [ __ ] diners
dude 24 hours the
it's a better the [ __ ] bread is the
breads are better you know because
because they get that [ __ ] from Europe
baby and it's [ __ ] right there on the
East Coast now it doesn't have to travel
all the way to the west coast and get
stale is [ __ ] they know how to make the
[ __ ] sandwich is better because
they're [ __ ] they literally they got
the [ __ ] guys who who did it over in
you know wherever the [ __ ] they're from
that's racist but yeah so no and and man
I went to I went to diners and shit's
our 24-hour it's just diners or the [ __ ]
man la he's got like four diners that
are open late at night and I missed that
[ __ ] so you better believe I went to the
[ __ ] diners I went to the diner and
weird [ __ ] will happen in diners in New
Jersey's first of all you got the most
Jersey people of all time it looked like
they there was a table that literally
look like it was the prequel to The
Sopranos like the [ __ ] hairspray and
the big hoop earrings and they were
saying not for nothing so much and the
[ __ ] big bulky guys and it was
definitely a guy that [ __ ] was
talking like this there but then they
lined up a bunch of tables I put this on
my snapchat a little bit but they line
up a bunch of tables and I was like god
what the [ __ ] I was talking to my opener
I was like why you think that they're
lining up those tables and he was like
my opener is one of those guys Mike
that'll [ __ ] come up with an opinion
about something like it's a fact and it
drives me up the [ __ ] wall
like he'll be like oh they're doing it
for brunch tomorrow and and I'm like you
don't know that [ __ ] you don't know it
you don't know it he did it the other he
did it he does it all the time and and I
think that's literally the definition of
a dum-dum like he goes like he said to
me one of my best friends love the guy
great guy funny onstage and but he'll
say [ __ ] like like Kevin Hart put up the
[ __ ] video of him apologizing for his
for something you know when Kevin on
Instagram sunny Instagram now but Kevin
Hart put her he was like I'm sorry you
know I made a bad mistake I just want to
put that out there I need to do better
for my family which is admirable
nobody knew what the [ __ ] he was talking
about it was very vague so Mike my
opener was like ah you know what
happened he got caught cheating she got
the evidence and then he [ __ ] had to
apologize and I was like you don't know
that you just and he was like nah that's
definitely what happened and I got blood
red mad cuz it's not because didn't know
and I said this is why you're a [ __ ]
idiot and he got so mad sulked left the
green room didn't come back till after
the show and I was like yo is this guy
[ __ ] really pissed off hahahaha
and then Marc was like yeah I think he
is my Irish buddy so anyway I [ __ ]
love the guy at the time I loved him
after that but so anyway what the [ __ ]
was I talking about um new New Jersey
diners so so he was like so he was like
yeah it's for brunch tomorrow morning
they're lining up the tables cuz
probably a lot of because a lot of big
cuz that's family time and families come
and I was like you don't [ __ ] know
that and then after he said that
literally I would say 50 Asian young
Asian men and women I mean they must
have been 20 walked in the diner like
[ __ ] one after another and just
filled up all of those tables and I
[ __ ] slammed his I slammed them dude
and I said see it wasn't for tomorrow
it's a [ __ ] Asian convention or
whatever the [ __ ] so many somany they
kept common dude so yeah so I had what I
eat I [ __ ] ate like a chicken
parmesan I went off the rails I usually
eat healthy nah not in New Jersey I
decided not to chew your parmesan I had
a [ __ ] tuna melt a huevos rancheros
dude I was I loved it these by the way
these Jersey diners they put they make
cheesecake factory menus look like a
[ __ ] bookmark dude it look it
literally looks like the [ __ ]
whatever you know what the cheat you
what the [ __ ] diners in in the diners
in New Jersey every single diner in New
Jersey you know what their menu looks
like
any book that any [ __ ] British
character is trying to find in a movie
about medieval times
that's what how big they are you put it
on the table Punk that's the book we
need this translates everything we've
learned in the past [ __ ] one hour and
45 minutes because this movie is too
long that's what the [ __ ] diner the
the menus in the diners look like in New
Jersey and and you need them and you
need like a key to open it up you know
like those [ __ ] stupid I swear to god
with these movies don't have like we
need a key to open the book what was a
movie I was just look I just flipping
through it it's like The Mummy or some
[ __ ] and it was like I can't open the
book we need the key and the girls like
the keys over there and he's like okay
and then somebody's about to die and the
guy finds the key and like unlocks the
book and it's like some [ __ ] key that
looks like a beetle or something you
know and he just got to put it in and
then it goes and then the legs come out
and then you twist it and then the book
opens and he's like la la la la la la la
and the guy dies you know he let but he
doesn't die he like disintegrates like
who the [ __ ] is making these movies
right who the [ __ ] like what is this
[ __ ] you can just make [ __ ] up until
it's until the movies over right you
know that's my problem with [ __ ]
science fiction or like whatever the
[ __ ] you call that I guess you know like
the ancient movies any movies about
ancient [ __ ] right where it's like where
it's like oh it starts off about a guy
and he's just like I'm looking for the
scrolls you know and then another older
guy or a kid it's never the guy who's
the [ __ ] same age as the guy right
they got to make it so different it's
like a little kid that's like I had once
the screws were who in [ __ ] you know
Longueville or wherever or the ancient
town of Babylon
hey hey by the way I'm 37 what the [ __ ]
is Babylon what is it
I don't know I don't know I've never
known I've never known what the [ __ ]
Babylon is Babylon is a key kingdom in
ancient myth it's probably ancient
Mesopotamia yeah every every time I
don't know where a [ __ ] place is that
sounds biblical it's in Mesopotamia
every [ __ ] time it was built on the
Euphrates River course it was and equal
parts along its left and right banks
with steep embankments to contain the
rivers seasonal floods Babylon was
originally a small Akkadian city dating
from the period of Akkadian Empire of
course it was oh yeah
so anyway they got to find the scrolls
and then the guys like alright I'll look
for the scrolls and so far you're
watching a movie and you're like I was
just looking for Scrolls and then all of
a sudden gets to the [ __ ] place and
then there's a guy who can like who's
like they are guarding the scrolls but
he's like a guy who can [ __ ] teleport
you're like well alright well so now
this guy just teleports and then it's
like so he teleports and then and then
it's like yeah but oh how do we defeat
him because he's teleporting and it's
like well you need the [ __ ] ancient
blocking system it blocks teleportation
and the guy can't teleport if you if you
can get this and you know and you're
like okay and you're watching the
[ __ ] movie like a goddamn CUDA you're
like oh yeah these things are happening
it's so hard to sustain a movie like
that because you need to create the
world and then adhere to the rules that
you created in that world right the best
movie that does that is the [ __ ]
matrix it really sets it up nice and a
[ __ ] everything all the dots connect
a movie that doesn't do that is the last
movie The Mummy with Tom Cruise I watch
that movie like this and you're only
gonna be able to see this on the video
podcast this is how I watch the movie
Russell Crowe was in it which was the
best they tried to set that [ __ ] up so
much they were like like Tom Cruise was
in it and he was the mummy and the
Russell Crowe comes in and he's like I'm
dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde though and also
there will be a movie about a werewolf
with Benicio del Toro in it later and
then Tom Cruise runs is there been a
movie where Tom Cruise doesn't run so
yeah so I don't know how I started
talking about oh so that's what the
[ __ ] diner thing looks like that's
what the diner thing looks like and then
the diner menu looks like and then you
can get like literally like a turkey
sandwich or [ __ ] baklava or you can
get whitefish hey if you can get
whitefish at a diner you know I would
say go to a different diner but that's
what the Jersey diners have man diners
have like everything ah the Jersey
doesn't have either but if dude if you
go to I was at I think I was a joke oi I
was a joke oi once my buddy
stand-up comedian [ __ ] extraordinary
jo koy and we went to a diner I think we
were the do bars in like the valley and
he got [ __ ] fish and I was like bro
who gets fish I'm sitting there eating a
[ __ ] like grilled chicken sandwich
and he got like [ __ ] white fish I was
like bro that's so gross and he was like
who the [ __ ] would get white fish at a
diner that's like you're just gonna [ __ ]
yourself so hard later I'll have stomach
problems he'll get the grill check it
chicken and I'll just have [ __ ] in my
brains out Thank You makuta um so yeah
so I went to the diners I went three
times creature habit babies creature
habit woke up got Starbucks
went back worked out then did my shows
then went to a diner creature habit
babies it's all I do you want to find
crystalline on the road find the closest
Starbucks or diner
creature habit babies I literally do the
same thing every day it's [ __ ]
awesome dude it's
awesome but don't you want to travel a
lot by but don't you want to go by but
don't you want to try see ya
but what if [ __ ] sayonara I'll do
what I figured out I like but don't you
want to see the oops but maybe there's a
step out gunk figured it out I'm 37
should know what I want to do hey want
to play flag football bye did you want
to go stand in line and [ __ ] eat the
best pancakes oops
no let's catch you later but let's take
the dogs and go to catch on the sequel
not watching the first one I mean
they're getting so so so not nonsensical
what I'm saying but it they all make
sense and if you're a [ __ ] true baby
you get it dude you get it you [ __ ]
get it man people showed up and dude
people show up to my shows and they're
[ __ ] saying hey proud member of the
cult babies that's what I'm talking
about man that's what I'm [ __ ]
talking about
you're showing up in your CUDA shirts or
your [ __ ] congratulations shirts this
is what I'm talking about man and pretty
soon we'll be the [ __ ] people that
they're making the movies about and
we'll be the ancient ones and you got to
[ __ ] find the scrolls that the elder
scrolls dude we're naming an elder today
by the way
we're naming an elder today baby
this is dick phyto we're naming an elder
today so stay tuned for that man I want
I want to get dick fight al to [ __ ]
say that for me and help me out do it I
was at the Starbucks in New Brunswick
and this guy wherever I go I get an iced
americano that's it sometimes I show up
these guys know what I want the
Starbucks barista will be like you want
an iced americano Chris now
that is my favorite part of the day
unless I'm performing I don't have to
say extra [ __ ] this is what I've
designed my life to do I just want to
walk around not say anything to anybody
and just feel what you're feeling and
just go about your day and then [ __ ]
get to perform at night and then go home
go to a diner [ __ ] chill out dude
design your life the way you want to man
Tony Robbins [ __ ] sure even
though Tony Robbins literally sounds
like a [ __ ] devil doesn't mean he's
not that guy
you watch that documentary holy [ __ ] man
but uh anyway I'm getting off here
getting off track here what was I just
saying oh so I was at the Starbucks and
the guy the guys like what do you want
and I said oh I'll get an iced americano
but do me a favor can you put less water
in it and just more ice now for those of
you that don't know what a my iced
americano is here's what it is okay it's
literally shots of espresso with water
in it and that's it and then an ice and
that's it okay that's what I get that's
my thing iced americano with [ __ ]
iced americano I don't put [ __ ] in
it so whenever they say like do you want
room for now by the way do you want room
for nah and I don't want room for [ __ ]
I'll just [ __ ] pour some [ __ ] out if
I need it and I'm not gonna be the
[ __ ] that pours out in the trash can
because that's pieces of [ __ ] because
then the trash cans leakin and you're
making everyone's job difficult I'll go
outside to do it I'll do it in the sink
that they always have or whatever the
[ __ ] or I'll pour it on my opener if
it's hot so I say to the guy can you do
me a favor and can you just not put so
much water in it and and and put more
ice in it now I've been getting this
drink for years and years and the guy
looks at me and says
well I would but that's literally
impossible and I said what and he says
well an iced americano is espresso with
water in it I said yeah I know and he
said so I would put less water in it but
that's literally impossible and I said
and I said oh well not it's not I mean I
didn't know how it is one of those times
were like when somebody like tells you
something that is just not true and then
you're like oh well how do I say that
the how do I say this
in response to how do I respond to this
guy without seeming like a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
right because what he's saying is wrong
so I just said oh now you could just put
less water in it right and he was like
no and I said and then I said well just
put less water in it and he said okay
and then he put less water in it so it's
not literally impossible also the fact
that he said literally impossible made
me want to [ __ ] punch up his face
like a [ __ ] punching back just say
impossible okay you never need to say
literally impossible just say impossible
impossible is a very strong word and it
takes care of itself you don't need you
don't need any [ __ ] what would it be
adjective before impossible unless it's
like virtually which means not
impossible it's an adverb right yes okay
well I don't know you know because I'm
[ __ ] dum-dum
my-my producer does know and he told me
so one hiram not one fire by the way
somebody tweeted me [ __ ] a guy it was
like Oh finally found Chris's producer
and they any screenshot of it on
Facebook and the guy's name was Juan
fire
they're like fa y ER or something one
haha [ __ ] man go on fire on fire say yes
so he said was literally impossible but
whatever um by the way those [ __ ]
movies about the ancient shits you know
what I tried to watch our movie I'm not
gonna name what it is because I'm
willing to accept that it was a good
movie but I'm just a [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
okay so I don't wanna bash the movie
because there was really good acting in
it but what's with these [ __ ] movies
that come out that are like about I sort
of God there's always like six of them
out whether it's in the theaters or or
on that I'll just like they'll show up
on iTunes in a bit what the [ __ ] is this
movie and it's like they're like there's
or they're on Netflix or Hulu or some
[ __ ] and it's a new release with these
[ __ ] movies that are like they're
always like they take place in like the
1700s in Britain and like everyone's
wearing [ __ ] off white or brown or
beige and boots and it's so brown or
green out and they're in castles and and
literally nothing goddamn happens and or
like somebody died before the movie
started and like there's a widow and
like I I haven't seen girl with a Pearl
Earring but it's like that like that
movie I'm sure that movie is good I
think it was nominated for some [ __ ] but
like that style of movie and and and and
and there's like British actors in it
but like one famous person in it in
America and then the rest of them are
like old guys that you've seen in movies
where you're like oh yeah that guy
played a [ __ ] bad guy in like you
know in one of the bond the movies or
some [ __ ] and that's his [ __ ]
breakout role but he's in
like like the movie will be called like
the lovely manuscript you know and like
somebody died before the movie and then
they will walk around and and they're
like and like they have tea together and
like they look at each other and they
and everything's so awkward
for no [ __ ] reason right like two
people fall in love and they're having
tea and they're like oh well I know you
like your tea like this because you told
me and they're like and the other person
you sure know me quite well and then the
other person's like your father
nom-nom-nom-nom huh and then they're
like my father sure was man and I'm Nana
and the fireplace is going and then they
just go like oh my it's getting late
isn't it I must go please no I must go
please no I must go okay well don't go
and then the British lady is like my oh
my
and then she sips her tea and like
that's the scene that's the [ __ ]
scene and we're supposed to feel bad for
her because her husband died before the
movie started and now she's got a
romance with some [ __ ] younger guy
that's got like [ __ ] blonde hair and
he's wearing off-white in beige and
that's the movie and every scene is that
scene and and in the end and maybe I'm a
dumb [ __ ] and I'm not saying every
movies got to be fast in the Furious
that movie sucks fat donkey balls as
well cuz Ludacris isn't it
cuz Ludacris is in it if Ludacris is in
a movie it's bad if I run for goddamn
mayor which I never will but if I do my
platform is going to be vote for me if
Ludacris is in a movie it's bad
unless you put Ludacris in the British
movie then I'll watch it and it will be
great if he's got to wear fluffy [ __ ]
Beethoven collars and and any and and
and she's like would you like a spot of
tea and he's just like nah nah I'm
straight and they're like Ludacris can
you please say the British line and he's
like nah my characters way too real
[ __ ] dude Ludacris his face you
know he always looks like he's so over
whatever the [ __ ] every picture of him
is like I'm tired of this [ __ ] man be
happy you got four million dollars oh my
god dude I'm looking at pictures of
Ludacris right now you know cool facial
hair anyway anyway what's what's that
movie dude it keeps coming out these
boring his [ __ ] [ __ ] 1,700 time
period [ __ ] British movies where a
girl loses a necklace and like a [ __ ]
young guy has to help her find it and
then a [ __ ] old guy you've seen is in
it in the movie that's a great actor but
he's always in it who's that [ __ ] guy
that's in in the movie for sure
what the [ __ ] his name calm calm Meany
is that a guy call that guy that [ __ ]
calm Mimi is in it yup
that [ __ ] guy's in it let's just look
at the titles of the calm meanie movies
the British ones of course can't find
one now because all the ones that
there's one the journey what the [ __ ] is
that one it's so iced Irish Oh coming
he's Irish right I think he is Irish
yeah
he's a great actor uh but anyway how
old's ego right a little bit 64
well if I got to do a movie with colm
Meaney I'll [ __ ] piss hair very
awesome I want to be one of those
British movie so bad well excuse me
excuse me your dress it's quite
revealing and it just shows your neck
you're not wearing your collar I've got
a boner you're not wearing a collar
therefore I squirt it in my pants um I
keep squirting I keep squirting when she
walks around because she doesn't because
her outfit is too revealing and it just
shows like her [ __ ] calves I can't
contain myself I can't contain myself
she keeps showing me but no her knees
and I keep squirting out of my boner and
then Carmina comes up and he's like stop
squirting out of your boner what would
your father think and I'd say my
father's dead
he doesn't think anymore and that's when
you realize oh I don't like calm meanie
because I've always been under his thumb
and I need my own life and then the
[ __ ] woman finds her necklace and I
put it around her neck and that's when
you realize that we're in love
I mean this is a movie that's a [ __ ]
movie that was probably made and then I
put the [ __ ] thing around her neck
and then we blink so much because we're
so awkward and she says oh I believe I
forgot in my place and then I say no you
and just found it and then I kiss her
cheek and I [ __ ] squirt and then the
movies like got one more scene where
like I weigh on a carriage going to like
[ __ ] you know for like I got to go
somewhere for three days but really it
takes three days to get there then I
stayed there for like a week and then I
got I could take three days and get back
and you don't know if I'm gonna come
back because that's what the [ __ ]
movies about and it's called the
beautiful [ __ ]
you script because we're talking about
manuscripts all the time or some
[ __ ] but that's a [ __ ] movie I
literally that's a movie that [ __ ]
would be on like you dudes you just
scroll around on iTunes and you'd be
like guys [ __ ] movie huh they made
this [ __ ] movie and it's able cost
like 11 million dollars to make put
Ludacris in that [ __ ] movie wink you
know look I'm not a drinker and you know
that if you're a [ __ ] true baby look
I'm not a drinker but it doesn't mean I
don't like to entertain and when my
guests can have great wine and I don't
have to worry about what I'm buying I'm
happy so I'm gonna tell you bout a
company called wink winc they give you
act they give you access to exceptional
wines from around the world just go to
try wink calm spelled T ry winc calm
take a brief pallet profile quiz and
wink will recommend distinct and
interesting wines actually customized to
your palate to be shipped directly to
your door every month it's not wasted
your time isn't wasted filling in or
filling out a fitting in a run to the
store or on your way home from work you
just go home and your wine will be there
because they deliver it
wink bases the wines they send you on
your taste preferences so it's cool I
had people here the other day and I had
plenty of wine going to go around
because of wink and I got compliments on
it they liked it and so it was awesome I
got to I got to do you know I got to
play host or whatever which I don't even
do but it was a I was able to do it
because a wink
there's no membership fees which is cool
he could skip any month cancel anytime
and wink has a 100% satisfaction
guarantee
right now wink is offering my listeners
$20 off your first order when you go to
try wink calm / Congrats that's try wink
spelled t ry wi and c.com / Congrats get
20% off your first order now try wink
calm / Congrats blinka look I like
knowing stuff I like to read but I
often don't have the time introducing
the blinka Stapp over 2,000 of the
best-selling non-fiction books transform
into powerful packs you can read or
listen to in just 15 minutes
blink Asst you can feast your mind on
the key ideas from top best-selling
non-fiction books like how to stop
worrying and start living the 4-hour
workweek and Rich Dad Poor Dad alright
you'll learn the essential ideas from
the best books in your field covering
topics like productivity busyness
science and self-improvement plus you
uncover subjects you never knew about
but you love so you can sound smart at
parties
Forbes BuzzFeed New York Times
Lifehacker are all talking about this
app blinkin and they were chosen in
Apple and Google's best of selection for
two years and the app is used by over 2
million users so don't be less left out
right now blinka stays a special offer
just for our audience go to blink st.com
/ Congrats right now to start your free
trial or get three free months off your
yearly plan when you join today that's
blinka spelled bli NK ist blink east
comm / Congrats to start your free trial
or get three months off your yearly plan
drinketh blink is calm / Congrats square
cache babies everyone is switching to
this cash app because it's the easiest
and best way to pay people back friends
family co-workers British people
Asians whites sending and receiving
money is totally free and fast and most
payments can be deposited directly into
your bank account in seconds here's how
it works
idiots download the square cash app link
to your debit card or credit card select
an amount to send and type in a friend's
phone number or email address to
complete a payment they'll give it a
notification that they just received the
money that's it no gimmicks Square cash
is better than the other guys it isn't a
social network if you have a social
network and you square in your in your
pay app yokota good gunk by
congradulations combo for that ass so
let's talk about the new cash card it's
a new black
a debit card that you can design
yourself via the app the cash card
allows you to use the cash that you keep
in the app everywhere and anywhere you
want you'll get notifications for all
payments made with the card directly via
the cash app it's awesome you can laser
at your card to personalize it and it
will be delivered directly to you for
free the cash app team is constantly
building new features so what are you
doing using the other guys get the cash
app today download the free cash app for
iOS or Android now I saw people online
saying oh you got to read the things you
got to read the ads yeah man what the
[ __ ] yeah of course I got to read it you
think I can memorize all that [ __ ]
imagine how long I'd have to study to
memorize that when I could just read it
on piece of paper okay come here come
here butters come here fat [ __ ] come
here you fat [ __ ] jump up you can do it
and he's [ __ ] too fat Sam come here
there you go Bubba good boy
so yeah so anyway all right guys I told
you we were gonna name the first elder
today and we were and we are now we we
we picked one and it's someone I don't
know and they've gone above and beyond
and they've influenced this show a
little bit even so the first elder elder
and I said Elber but what I meant was
elder because sometimes you [ __ ] up okay
now I get always when I make a mistake
like that if I say élber my heart gets
like I beat a little bit because I get
[ __ ] mad that I did that but I'm an
elder and the first elder the first
elder that is being or the first person
that is being made an elder and get on
with it is at is at a plum balm Adam a
now this guy's been a baby from the
beginning and I know he's listening
because he hears every episode and he's
coined the term this is what this is one
of the reasons why we made him an elder
because he's coined the term gaming the
system he was the first guy that said it
was too easy to game the system and he
always asked questions every week so
he's been obviously very influential to
the show and now what do you get if
you're an elder and this is what you get
you get a certificate and an exclusive
little pin that you cannot purchase only
elders will have these we will DM with
the details
so congratulations a plumb bomb Adam a I
I'm spending my own money to send these
pins to you okay and we will announce an
elder as the show's progressed we will
announce more and more elders now that's
that's what you get and thank you for
your your your listener ship and your
viewer ship or whatever that's it we'll
be naming more maybe next episode
so everybody wish him a congratulations
that's the congratulations way
congratulations you're an elder so yeah
I saw the movie uh it and it was [ __ ]
scary dude that guy who plays this the
[ __ ] clown was scary I mean that
mostly cuz of the makeup and [ __ ] but he
drooled in it which is awesome he was
drooling so much and then one time he
there's one time in the show in the
movie in the beginning where he's in the
in the I'm not running anything but when
he's in the gutter and he [ __ ] laughs
like my buddy Zach he's talking to the
kid and he goes and I was like oh I
laughed so hard you remember him from a
few episodes ago I was the guy but yeah
that guy who played the [ __ ] think
guy was scary man that [ __ ] thing was
scary but you know what [ __ ] bugs me
dude is everyone jumping on the [ __ ]
bandwagon that clowns are scary
no no clowns are not scary scary clowns
are scary you [ __ ] Cudas scary clowns
are scary
this clown fear [ __ ] is so annoying
people just think it makes them [ __ ]
interesting do you not I mean these
[ __ ] dudes
I feel like mostly its chicks but maybe
not chicks on Instagram that's like on a
[ __ ] thing like oh my god you know I
have a fear of clowns but I went to go
see it anyway you don't know a [ __ ]
fear of clowns you have a fear of
[ __ ] killers you saw a movie about a
killer clown you [ __ ] CUDA step out
turn round good thunk the door hit you
on your [ __ ] fake ass on the way out
dude that's such a [ __ ]
congratulations combo with an extra tag
at the end about how I [ __ ] hit your
fake ass because of the [ __ ] IG world
man don't be a CUDA we all have a little
bit of CUDA in us it's just how it is
you can't be human and not be CUDA but
keep that [ __ ] CUDA level down
diminish the [ __ ] CUDA yeah man you
know you'll have a sphere of clowns dude
you have a fear of demon clowns
it's like saying I've got this crazy
fear of serial killers hey miss [ __ ]
like this hit this [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
subtitles and then hitting this [ __ ]
with the ball that goes over it hit no
[ __ ] for kids hey kids you got a fear of
clowns hit Nick [ __ ] Aichi neh [ __ ] with
the ball hey no [ __ ]
yeah so what's that
anyway um it's just like what was the
last thing that was like that where it
was like oh [ __ ]
you know what was such a [ __ ] CUDA
thing was the march of the Penguins
hey that movie was [ __ ] boring I want
to go see that because everyone was
talking about how [ __ ] good march of
the Penguins was and you know what it
was
penguins marching say yeah everyone was
talking about how good this [ __ ]
movie march of the Penguins was and I
had to go see it because everyone was
talking about how good it wasn't it was
narrated by Morgan Freeman and oh you
feel really you actually feel for these
penguins and oh they are monogamous
isn't that beautiful
nah hey if you're a penguin [ __ ] a lot
of other penguins or ye borin you're an
animal what are you trying to be
faithful for your to your [ __ ] female
penguin for for what she's a penguin
dude if I was dating a penguin I would
cheat on it all the [ __ ] time
imagine being monogamous to a penguin
even if you're a penguin the [ __ ] you
chump betta [ __ ] you betta [ __ ]
penguin you coulda asked [ __ ]
dude no dude step out of the igloo gunk
slide all the way back down to the
[ __ ] dude
that I know but the mommy sits on the
[ __ ] child for a long time and
doesn't move oh really
and I gotta watch that [ __ ] that's
boring is it cute really you know what
else is cute my two dogs I'll look at
them and Morgan Freeman won't be like
your two dogs are sitting there dude
that movie was so [ __ ] boring you
know what I could have done googled
penguins marching watched some videos
and then read the Wikipedia page by
that was some serious like [ __ ] that
would but that's the same thing as the
scary clown thing you jumping on the
[ __ ] bandwagon dude burn that
bandwagon how many people are at Burning
Man that really want to be at Burning
Man how many people how many [ __ ]
people and let me tell you those people
clinically insane that actually want to
be there all the other people that are
there are there because they think they
should be there or they don't want to
miss out or they think no those two
reasons and either of those reasons coda
and either of those reasons I protect I
present you CUDA and either of those
reasons I protect I present you in a
high digital Dolby sound CUDA I present
you an IMAX theater we'll see you later
all right
penguins marching around [ __ ] off
march of the Penguins guys made that
documentary
they froze their [ __ ] asses off and
videoed penguins sitting on each other
for months
hey guy who did that go to a city [ __ ]
someone hey guy who did that go to a
city eat some stuff at a restaurant [ __ ]
a girl [ __ ] a guy she doin hey guy chu
doin hey guy
filming a [ __ ] oh hey oh hey just
found out the director of march of the
Penguins name
guess what of course it is oh my god
dude oh my god way do you hear this
guy's name who directed march of the
[ __ ] Penguins Luke jacket or jacket
or some [ __ ]
how do you [ __ ] pronounce that
Jacquet Lucas okay hey guys
based on the name guess if the [ __ ]
name Luke has a K at the end of it or it
ends with a C French is shared do
nothing is more French than [ __ ]
shooting videoing animals doing nothing
there it is
the penguin as it sits on the other
penguin and never Fox any other penguin
ever again because it is monogamous
creature
it should absolutely go [ __ ] other
penguins because whatever it is doing it
is unnecessarily because the other
penguin will not get mad at it if it
goes er then focusing on a penguin
because that was a Oh penguin that this
female won't be like well hell have you
been I have been waiting for you to get
home and had to watch movies on Netflix
waiting for you as your food got cold
and now you are back and you smell like
soup and you don't use you
so I should go to a city and the [ __ ]
someone oh he's got tiny circular
glasses found an image of him where he's
got tiny circular glasses couldn't look
more French dude if you're French and
you have tiny circular glasses and you
look and and so much so to where they're
so tiny that if you're looking straight
on that you can still see the legs of
the glasses because they're so tiny and
then the [ __ ] legs are parts are
[ __ ] widening out even on a
straight-on shot and you know what I'm
[ __ ] talking about then you were born
in France and you are still in France
and you have never left France even if
you leave France then wherever you are
that's France
you could be in [ __ ] Zimbabwe
wherever you are that counts as France I
would like new glasses do you have do
you have glasses that you can see the
legs of the classes even still a ton
even though you shouldn't I will get
those because I am NOT for ya bro so
anyway what I was going to talk about
some [ __ ] figure clowns and [ __ ] but
whatever what now I was gonna talk about
the Emmys but it's like I just don't I
don't I don't know
every actor goes up there in his psyche
and also recycle you're like oh yeah
dude
you know you were in a [ __ ] movie or
a TV but TV movie hey I just wanted to
let you know you know thanks to my
wonderful director my beautiful director
this is the penguin Luke jacket he was
so cold for so long and I sat on another
I sat on my daughter penguin for so long
and I'm sure my husband a penguin didn't
[ __ ] anyone else
that's how we penguins are Luke jacket
thank you thank you Luke jacket even
though you should have went to a city
and [ __ ] someone please recycle thank
you tonight then and rent they know when
we come back a beetle from Planet Earth
yeah Neil and Anna intend Anna Anna this
is the this is the goat that stands on a
wall this is the goat that stands on the
side of the mountains second Emmy he was
first nominated for planet Earth
now he's nominated for the documentary
goat standing on the side of a wall
precariously for some reason what are
those [ __ ] things are called like
Ynez or some [ __ ] they stand on the side
of a [ __ ] wall what are they [ __ ]
called why doesn't that [ __ ] oh the
ibex that's what it's called hey why
don't hey ibex is why are you not
falling ibex is stand on the side of
these [ __ ] walls and the walls have
nothing on it they could literally stand
on a [ __ ] flat wall ibex is hey ibex
do you have a deal with Satan hey ibex
how do you suck and stick to the side of
a wall hey ibex use this stairs the [ __ ]
is an ibex doing dude I bet that's the
[ __ ] sexiest animal dude I swear to
God other female ibex look at male ibex
and they're [ __ ] [ __ ] get so wet
that they slip and fall and their
forelegs shoot out from under them
because they're like how does he [ __ ]
do it all ibex are David Copperfield
dude how the [ __ ] do i bec stand on the
side of the wall like that they
literally are just scrunched up against
the wall standing on nothing
hey dude how do you make march of the
[ __ ] Penguins when you should make
[ __ ]
out of the wall ibex make that [ __ ]
documentary there the ibex is stuck to
the side of the wall little Ellie
nothing is under his feet how does it do
it magic or nothing I mean some ancient
people say that this side of the ibex is
sticky therefore it cannot fall but we
all know that it is not you because I
mean Google some of these [ __ ] things
will have them on the video podcast for
sure we'll show you it's ibex I mean
look at this [ __ ] thing walking dude
look at this thing walking on the side
of a wall the walls [ __ ] 90 degrees
anyway I don't you know when we come
back and ibex
Ami's also what's going on in the world
Hey also what's going on in the world
was terrible we shouldn't be pushed to
be something that we're not we should be
not in the protests and if you protest
then it's good and also you should
recycle just so you know because so many
dolphins are getting strangled because
of coke bottle holder together anyway
I'd really like to thank everyone I
loved doing my role in narcos you know I
loved doing my role in Westworld
recycle I played a robot I I played a
[ __ ] robot
thanks for the Emmy by the way everybody
what's going on on the other side of the
world make sure we save everybody thanks
for the gold bye thanks for giving me
gold now I'll make ten million dollars
on my next project because of this also
babies need to learn more by I mean
really dude
take your [ __ ] award say thanks
[ __ ] congratulate your cast mates
yeah it's an honor also see yeah yeah
but anyway so like [ __ ] sit every
time my buddy texts me I've got a buddy
that texts me about like girls that he's
seeing and he always does the slow play
and he takes so long like he'll be like
yeah I don't know I don't know if she's
into me or whatever and I always text
him
I [ __ ] always text him a picture of
an ibex on the side of a wall because
like that's what he is he's just [ __ ]
standing in the middle of nowhere
shouldn't be and like figure it out
anytime you have a buddy that's like oh
no if she likes me or like hung out with
a girl seven times and hasn't like
[ __ ] at least gotten the like third
base whatever that is or even know what
that is dick-sucking or whatever like
you know socratic him a picture of an
ibex stuck on the side of the wall
because that's what that [ __ ] is
you hang out with a girl seven eight
times didn't kiss her yah ex hey dude
you've hung out with a girl seven times
and all you did was hold her hand
and never got your dick touched yah X
that's what you are sweat jar yah Becks
no take your dick out hey dude the IBEX
stopped taking her to a movie have a
date at home or hype X I mean dude come
on man get it going dude
oh I don't know though you know I don't
know if she's into me
yeah backs hang out with her twice hang
out with her three times and you hang
out with her four times you can
crouching on IBEX territory [ __ ]
standing in the middle of boom your
buddy I want to see screenshots as your
[ __ ] baby duties I want to see
screenshots of you I don't know if she
your buddy texts you I don't know if
she's into me I don't know if he's into
me whatever it is text a picture of an
ibex on the side of the wall and write
that right to your buddy he ibex why
[ __ ] ' ibx
it's like Kakuta only different so yeah
goats on the side of a wall man or if
it's two people with divots two people
be like oh this is the two of you and
shut two goats on a wall this is the two
of you this is what the - you guys did
last night cool anyway all right all
right let me look at my let me see if I
have a good one and I you know what I
actually did find a good eye what do you
call it Instagram post since the
Internet is always really really [ __ ]
shinty on this side of the [ __ ] here
we go here we go this one was actually
an ad I found and this is great hey guys
it's time for the most [ __ ] up
Instagram post of the week
[Music]
okay guys now this is an ad and it is
not a post from someone but is a post
from something called awesome t-shirt
which you can follow I don't even know I
can't even click on it so I don't know
what the [ __ ] maybe it's not there
anymore but you know I don't know how
these ads you know you'll be scrolling
through you do you're on the phone with
your buddy and you mention like [ __ ]
you know Rihanna and then like you go on
Instagram later and and like and and
then you scroll through all your feed
and then all of a sudden there's [ __ ]
your it says it shows a post that
Rihanna's come into [ __ ] the area
that you're coming in your if you want
to buy Rihanna tickets and you're like
oh okay cool so because I said Rihanna
on the phone and now that now that
Instagram knows that and they're sending
me maybe I want to get Rihanna tickets
I'm supposed to believe that the world
isn't doomed cool so this is something
like that I don't know why I got an
awesome t-shirt ad but maybe I [ __ ]
mentioned awesome t-shirts so this is
the shirt they're trying to sell it
doesn't even have it says buy it here in
the comment but this is the shirt
another guy is really really buff of
course because if there's an Instagram
post of someone wearing a shirt
promoting something the guys got to be
such a kit looks terrible now so okay
now I don't know I found this one in
June and this is it says in in the
[ __ ] on the shirt it's got like one
of those you know I'm gonna screenshot
it and tweet it actually but it's got
one of those like things you get what do
you call those things on like these
things on like the side of like
nutrition fact guides on the side of a
anything you buy at the supermarket and
on the top it says June guy facts which
I guess if you're born in June you can
get this shirt and I'm sure you can get
it in every other month because it is an
awesome t-shirt and I'm sure that
awesome t-shirts I'm sure they want to
make money so they got all the months
and they make you feel real good get
[ __ ] kuda so sir this should just blew
my [ __ ] mind dude did servings per
container 24/7 alright
so already that's so wrong
don't even look it up let me read it to
you dude already it's so wrong okay June
guy facts servings per container 24/7
already it's not a good idea because it
doesn't fit in with what you're doing
right already trying to fit a [ __ ]
square peg in a round hole okay here we
go
oh my god and then it's got the
percentage daily value and under it okay
it's got all the [ __ ] ingredients
quote-unquote and all the freakin
percentages of the ingredients I mean
unbelievable protective as hell one
hundred and fifty five percent okay so I
guess that means overprotective cute I
mean I don't even know what this is
already off the rails psychic psychic
120 percent psychic okay artistic 100
percent so less than being psychic and
less than reading protective as hell
which is which already you're dealing
with a [ __ ] crazy person I'm more
protective than I am son artistic but a
more psychic than I am artistic too okay
rebellious 90% so you still follow ten
percent of the rules this is one of my
favorites tell it like it is a hundred
percent which means you never don't tell
it like it is this is actually
unbelievable this one loyal to a fault
two hundred percent which is great
because that meet that like I always
love how every [ __ ] like mother
[ __ ] like ball and ask some
[ __ ] thinks they're the most
loyal person and and like bad ass
[ __ ] the girls that coin themselves
I'm a badass [ __ ] I'm like cuz I'm a
hundred percent loyal this guy's two
hundred percent loyal like you're not
you know you can be pretty loyal or you
can be really loyal that's it that's
[ __ ] it
you're not [ __ ] like everybody is a
goddamn you know everybody's in a
Ludacris song loyal to my dog you're not
DMX you're [ __ ] some guy you know who
works that [ __ ] watch over your bank
Wachovia Bank you know you're not a
[ __ ] look
what do you loyal fool what what's that
mean you call your friends back whoa
loyal to a fault two hundred percent by
the way that's not good to a fault is
not good
just put loyal this guy's so loyal he
[ __ ] his own life up is that what that
means he's too loyal that he [ __ ] up
other people's lives is that what that
means you [ __ ] dumb Jun guy facts
shirt okay here we go here we go here we
go here we go temperamental why is this
one even on it temperamental
195 like they're actually thinking like
well not not as much as loyal to a fault
like you know that'd be crazy but pretty
[ __ ] close
I'm temperamental hi that's bad that's
bad to be that temperamental imagine
saying you should meet my friend Derek
oh yeah yeah he's a he's he's a hundred
and ninety-five percent temperamental
he'd be like oh I'll never want to meet
that guy but and then the guy will be
like yeah but he's a hundred and ninety
percent psychic okay I'll take my
chances he's one hundred fifty five
percent protective as hell though okay
after loyal to a fault and temperamental
problem-solving okay
105 percent so a little over a hundred
percent you can solve any problem and
any problem that might arise later that
doesn't even exist in the world yet I
guess is what that means by the way my
favorite is that never has anything been
below 100 percent except for rebellious
so he kind of stays in line but also
he's protective as health psychic
artistic tell it like it is loyal to a
fault temperamental and problem-solving
off the charts literally okay then the
next one is lie detecting one hundred
and fifty five percent which is the same
I might add as protective as hell so as
much as he can protect you and over
protect you he can also tell if you're
[ __ ] lying which which means he's got
to be a [ __ ] to be in a
relationship with this is my favorite
this is my favorite one they get better
and better and which is amazing cause it
starts with protective as hell which is
my fit which is my favorite when I first
read it and then I keep getting better
and they been getting better and better
okay I like this one because it has a
caveat on it sweetest if treated well
and this one is a whopping five hundred
percent so if you treat this guy well
he's five five hundred percent sweet how
sweet is that just always talking to you
like this and putting sugar in your
mouth and rub in your back who wants
that dry the [ __ ] yeah try the [ __ ]
out dry but yeah try the [ __ ] out dry
the [ __ ] up this is the last one and
this is so would be the last one with a
guy who would wear this shirt okay
dangerous when provoked
guess how much percent guess all for
sure
1,000% yo straight up don't [ __ ] with
guys only born in June I mean this is
just supposed to be guys born in June
you know are there other ones but put
what April guy facts it's the same
[ __ ] thing right if it's the same
thing I'll [ __ ] I swear to God if
it's the same [ __ ] thing go ahead
over there oh it's the same [ __ ]
thing
yo [ __ ] this [ __ ] imagine wearing this
and being a Jun guy fact and then seeing
another guy January guy fact and he's
got the same percentages and [ __ ] you
[ __ ] dicks at the end it says daily
value may vary huh you [ __ ] dicks if
you ever get a [ __ ] shirt like that I
swear to god you're the biggest khuda of
all time you're the biggest [ __ ] code
of all time if you get that [ __ ] [ __ ]
any facts that aren't facts ah kick out
the door good gunk protective a selca
gunk psychic cocoon artistic the gunk
tell it like it is qug UNK I got 10
doors for your [ __ ] I got 10
doors this is noises off in this [ __ ]
you wear that shirt it's [ __ ] noises
off in this [ __ ]
gunk gunk gunk gunk I'm so heated I'm
not even taking [ __ ] hey a plumb bomb
go back to a blonde bomb sting well go
to a plumb bomb the first elders home
page there's gues 70 difference you got
more haircuts than [ __ ] DeNiro anyway
Congrats
congratulations to the first Albert
elder
we're wrapping this up we're not taking
[ __ ] should we take [ __ ] I went out
to take questions [ __ ] it you know it's
been an hour in ten minutes
hey have you guys switched to two square
cash yet download the free square cash
app design your cash card get it for iOS
or Android now we're wrapping up video
episodes go up on Thursdays if not
before so check the show out on YouTube
watch it you get to see me talk and [ __ ]
and not just listen to it we've got some
upcoming shows I'm gonna get to but
watch man on fire on Netflix if you
haven't watched it watch it and share
that with your friends I'd love it if
you watched it if you didn't watch it if
you didn't watch it here come the shows
my upcoming shows Charlotte North
Carolina Boone North Carolina and
playing the Appalachian State University
Charlotte North Carolina
adil Adelaide Australia Perth Australia
Melbourne Australia Sydney Australia
Brisbane Australia and then I'm gonna be
in Columbus Ohio in November or vine
California in November to December and
then San Jose San Jose California I'm
selling tickets really fast there so go
get them now San Jose and it or vine for
sure
Ohio Jessica Ohio just got put up but
listen I'm trying to grow this [ __ ]
podcast and get this cult going if if it
doesn't happen more and more we stop in
if you're not growing you're stalling
you know how it goes man so rate and
review this podcast please when you're
done with this and go tweet it to your
friends text it to your friends share it
on Instagram and help me out and grow
this cult you as a baby also news were
on Spotify so if you want to listen to
the podcast on Spotify you can do that
too now I don't know how you're gonna
learn that if you already listening to
it here now because this is where you're
listening to it but my producer asked me
to say that we're on Spotify even though
this isn't Spotify one fire one firearm
so Chris D'Elia calm or congratulations
calm Twitter is at congrats pod or
hashtag congratulations pod
and get these questions going to me
thank you very much
congratulations doc congratulations pod
comm Chris Leo calm rate and review
please do that and I'll see you at a
show
I'll see ya - oh soon take care of my
babies and remember free country